hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to undertale now we're
gonna see if toriel is actually not evil
by going into her home where she's
definitely not gonna cook me into dinner
do you smell that
surprise it's a butterscotch cinnamon
pie I thought we might celebrate your
arrival I want you to have a nice time
living here boy it would be really sad
if I ended up murdering everything on
the way over here that would be really
really sad so I will hold off on snail
pie for tonight here I have another
surprise for you oh this is lonely I
don't want to snoop around her house do
I this is it you're standing awfully
close to me after I entered this hallway
Oh a room of your own I hope you like it
this is really odd this monsters so nice
all the monsters were apparently driven
underground with this one so nice so
nice to me are you know once again
that's a little better okay oh oh
is something burning umm make yourself
at home okay
alright don't let the piper is something
bad gonna happen to her oh she's so nice
oh look at it look at these cool toys
they don't interest you at all but
they're cool
Oh am i sleeping I didn't mean go to
sleep wait I meant for there to be more
no idea I didn't mean for that you found
a slice of butterscotch cinnamon pie I
didn't I didn't mean to go to sleep oh
okay
oh man I actually meant to get the oh I
might have missed out on something a box
of kids shoes in disparity of sizes
ah okay just a regular old bucket of
snails I wasn't even looking at the
bucket its toriel's diary why would I
read the circle Padgett that's snooping
should i snooped
fine you read the passage why did the
skeleton want a friend because she was
feeling bone Lee oh-oh-oh-oh
an encyclopedia of subterranean plants
he opened the middle Tifa a group of
wetland flowering plants with brown
oblong seed pods no more commonly as
water sausages I don't know anything
about that
ah the cactus truly the most asunder des
Plantes okay
alright then so where is she room under
renovations okay it's me oh it's a water
sausage I just read about that so inside
the drawer flower seeds and some broken
crayons so why was there a box full of
children's shoes I'm one of the children
is it not good it might not be good I
have no idea
these books are worn they must have been
read many times hmm okay I'll come back
here later
that seems sinister I wonder what's
going on down there oh hey how's it
going up already I see um I want you to
know how glad I am to have someone here
there are so many old books I want to
share I want to show you my favorite bug
hunting spot I've also prepared a
curriculum for your education this may
come as a surprise to you but I have
always wanted to be a teacher
actually upset isn't very surprising
still I am glad to have you living here
oh did you want something
what is it let's see when can I go home
oh let's see what this this is your home
now um would you like to hear about this
book I'm reading it is called
seventy-two users whose nails how about
it ah well then then I can see where
this is going now
alrighty then here's an exciting snail
fact oh boy did you know that snails
make terrible shoelaces
interesting yeah well bother me if you
need anything else okay
I'm just gonna be on my way mmm the size
of the pie intimidates you do much for
you to eat it why why is that a thing
stove top is very clean toriel must use
fire magic and say does that make sense
how would you get to fire magic I don't
know inside the cupboard cookie cutters
for gingerbread monsters there is some
white fur stuck in the drain for some
reason there is a brand name chocolate
bar in the fridge
okay bizarre how do I get out here's a
random page try buying the barrier and
feel full of further human tax we
retreated far far into the earth we
walked until we reached the caverns end
this was our new home which we named Oh
as great as our King is he's pretty
lousy in names okay cool the ends of the
tools have been filed down to make them
safer Oh for me how do I get out of here
how do I get out of the ruins I have to
do something stay here what do you have
to do okay bye are you gonna barricade
the exit oh I hope that's it
uh says something about this has bad
feeling written all over it
let me save one more time saving seeing
such a cute tidy house okay so how do I
just out of here and where do did you go
did you want my room no did you go in
your room
no did you go in the renovation room
well that only leaves one option she
went downstairs so there must be
something in that basement that I I like
this is sneaking suspicion from all the
other games that I played this usually
is where things turn a little sinister
you wish to know how to return home do
you not ahead of us lies the end of the
ruins a one way exit to the rest of the
underground I am going to destroy it no
one will ever be able to leave again now
be a good child and go upstairs I knew
there was a reason why I gave her this
voice um lady
toriel toriel toriel Oh every human that
falls down here meets the same fate I
have seen it again and again they come
they leave they die you naive child if
you leave the ruins they our score will
kill you I am only protecting you do you
understand
go to your room but that seems like not
what I should do toriel do not try to
stop me this is your final warning final
warning why you have to be so sinister
toriel you want to leave so badly hmm
you are just like the others there is
only one solution to this prove yourself
prove to me you are strong enough to
survive oh oh no oh no I don't want to
hello
talk you couldn't think of any
conversation topics Oh oh goodness hey
oh wow geez
toriel looks through you I don't know if
I want to try to think of something to
say again but oh gosh oh my goodness
wowie Zowie Wow
okay prepares a magical attack I don't
know what to do about that
would you like a doughnut or a signer hi
would you like some pie how do I go back
can we talk
ironically talking does not seem to be
the solution to this situation okay
whoa oh I forgot about that acting aloof
would you like some pie I didn't mean to
eat it no I didn't mean to eat it Oh God
not this again whole ordeal ooh
oh goodness gravy gravy oh gosh can i
spare oh goodness gravy I don't know
what I'm supposed to be doing this is
this not easy Wow okay so I check Oh
knows best free I don't think she does I
don't think she do no best I am feeling
not very best taken care of Nastase
lord I got I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
aren't I Oh how do I run oh that is
right go upstairs
already what will it take for you to
learn your lesson
I don't know I'm probably gonna die
that's all I know how to do talk please
ah oh I'm gonna die ah ah oh what that's
a bunch of baloney okay so there's no
item that I could use there's nothing
that I could do uh I'm gonna die oh now
they're avoiding me
oh oh now she's a she
doesn't want to try to kill me okay I
see oh all the attacks are avoiding me
now huh hey hey hey come back you hit me
you hit me dang it you hit me you don't
want to kill me do you you don't wanna
you're not trying to come on come on
what you got you can't do it you can't
do it you just can't do it I'll spare
you this time oh look it's all avoiding
ah come here you hit me I want you to do
it hey buddy
am i okay so all I'm doing is I'm
sparing her repeatedly so hopefully she
started to change up what are you doing
I'm not doing anything you're not the
one who's trying to do the finishing
blow come on I'm just little Tim Tim
uh-huh little Tim Tim attack Oh run away
no I will not I refuse
I am merciful man if someone was playing
the violin route she just she wouldn't
kill you
she just wouldn't what are you proving
this way I'm proving that I am merciful
or something to that effect I'm not
entirely sure fight me or leave no I
will not just as you cannot kill little
Tim Tim that is me I cannot kill you
stop it no hit me hey come on in me stop
looking at me that way
no please oh my please I just want to go
home go away no I will I want to go home
please let me go home I just want to go
to my family
I'm uh-oh her eyebrows are giving her
away
oh no is toriel feeling a little bit sad
ah there we go
I know you want to go home but da da da
da T spare please go upstairs now
No
I promise I will take good care of you
here I bet I bet she would I really do
bet she would but I have to go home I
know we do not have much but oh now I'm
sad what would happen if in the game you
just decided to stay in the room oh we
can have a good life here I bet we could
oh why are you making this so difficult
please go upstairs oh it's so sad oh
haha pathetic is it not I cannot save
even a single child but you try no I
understand you would just be unhappy
trapped down here though ruins are very
small once you get used to them it would
not be right for you to grow up in a
place like this my expectations my
lonely is my fear Oh No
for you my child I will put them aside
all this so sad if you truly wish to
leave those ruins I will not stop you
however when you leave please do not
come back I hope you understand
this hos ad oh I feel heartbroken she's
so lonely she was just wanted to be a
good mama oh no she was so nice I'm just
a weird clothes ID I'm like Brock's
child oh this so bizarre that's so sad
why am I going I mean I have to I guess
I guess that's so sad I mean what the
game have just ended if I tried to go
back to the room and maybe go to sleep
oh now like I thought it was sinister
she actually oh hey hey clever very
clever you think you're really smart
don't shot in this world it's kill or be
killed so you were able to play by your
own rules you spared the life of a
single person hmm I bet you feel really
great you didn't kill anybody this time
but what will you do if you meet a
relentless killer you'll die and you'll
die and you'll die until you tire of
trying what will you do then
will you kill out of frustration will
you give up entirely on this world and
let me in Hera the power to control it I
am the Prince of this world future don't
worry my little monarch my plan isn't
regicide this is so much more
interesting oh hey you're creepy I don't
like you could you okay by flowey you
will always be my best of friends okay
wow they're so cool ah man it's amazing
of the simplest of games go oh
well I guess now we're playing the game
for real by toby fox cool okay hey the
lot this camera hidden in the bushes
that was a rock I did not think that was
a bush why is there a camera hidden in
the bushes dare I ask why there's a
camera hidden in the bushes okay I'll
just be on my way then
bunch of creepy ones don't know how I
got here
kinda underground seems bizarre that
there'd be a forest but little Tim Tims
it's gonna go on the way what would
happen if I walked over that it cracked
anyway horny losers something behind me
isn't there
is there something invisible stop okay I
saw that let me turn down to volume here
on my Mikey Mike so I don't blow nothing
out okay I have to hi hello I can't move
human don't you know how to greet new
pal turn around and shake my hand
Oh God anyway you're human right little
Aries um shines sounds skeleton I'm
actually moved to be on ones for humans
right now I don't like that voice oh you
know I don't really care about capturing
anybody know my brother papyrus I can't
decide on a voice for this guy he's a
human hunting fanatic maybe maybe he's a
redneck this guy sounds like there's a
human hunting fanatic no he's an even
hunting fanatic manna why can't I come
up with a redneck voice right now all of
the hair I want to make out with my
sister ah he's a human hunting fanatic
hi actually I think I see him over ere I
have an idea go through this guy thingy
no that's not why do I keep flipping out
of it all than I have an idea how there
go through this gate thingy no that's
not why can't I do redneck anymore
go through this guy thingy go through
this guy thing I go through this guy
thing only idea I have an idea I have an
idea go through this gate thingy yeah go
right through my bro made the bars too
wide to stop buying a buddy oh okay then
quick bond that conveniently shaped lamp
wow this is a really convenient lamp huh
well then tell Brown you know what's up
brother
it's been eight days and you still
haven't recorded your puzzles you just
hang around outside your station what
are you even doing staring out of lamp
really cool you won't look no I don't
have time for that what if a human comes
through here I want to be ready
I will be the one I must be the one I
will capture our human then I the great
papyrus will get all the things I
utterly deserve respect recognition I
will finally be able to join the Royal
Guard people will ask to be my friend
I will pay with a shower of kisses every
morning from my friends hmm maybe this
lamp will help you son you're not
helping you lazybones all you do is sit
and boondoggle you get lazier and lazier
every day I take it easier I got a ton
of work done by a skeleton he'll do oh
geez
sighs come on you're smiling
I am and I hate it
hey why does someone as great as Nicky
have to do so much just to get some
recognition
Wow sounds like you're really working
yourself down to the bone oh I will
attend to my puzzles as for your work
put a little more backbone into it okay
bye bye bony
okay bye Baba okay you can come out now
oh I'm moving now you ought to get going
they might come back and if he does
you'll have to sit through more of my
hilarious jokes and my hilariously
changing redneck accent talk your way of
speaking which I can't seem to nail down
some sorta checkpoint er some sort of
checkpoint or sentry station but there
are bottles of ketchup mustard and
relish [ __ ] inside
those hotdogs dad excuse me
okay so that was weird
I actually hate hate to bother you but
can you do me a favor
can you follow my accent I can't seem to
redneck right actually hi actually hi
actually hi hate to bother you hate to
bother you but couldn't do me a favor I
was thinking my brother's been kind of
down lately
he's never seen him before I seen you
might just make it day know her he's not
dangerous
even if he tries to be thanks a million
I'll be overhead okay alright then this
doesn't seem so bad I mean why are they
so worried about humans anyway it's not
like they drove him underground killed
all our family the convenience of the
lamp still fills you with determination
that was a right convenient lamp indeed
indeed II do okay this is a box you can
put an item inside or take an item out
the same box will appear later so don't
worry about coming back sincerely a box
lover well good for you
Tiny Tim is gonna put his items in a
tiny but tough glove that sounds good I
don't know what to do with the spider
cider in the donut I can't carry much oh
well maybe I can equipped how do I get
my menu how dare we go tough glove use
you equip tough glove hey I did that
good for me why do I have bandages my
armor I don't think I'm ever actually
gonna level up maybe I could call to
Oriel dialing nobody picked up oh no I
could tell her how I'm doing
Oh No oh hey snow Drake flutters North
High how about a joke you make a bad ice
button I've heard that one well how
about another one then oh hey oh I keep
it I I expected like toriel's level of
difficulty there smells like a wet
pillow laugh laugh at snow Drake before
it says anything funny what are you
laughing at I'm sorry I didn't mean to
do anything offensive I'm just
finding everything you're funny I'm
still laughing at the guys bad jokes
before still diggins practicing its last
pun um
snow Drake the steam comedian fights to
keep a captive audience better not
snowflake out ha ha ha
smiling ok so ha ha ha oh God
shad was wrong dad was wrong oh that
that has so many sad Oh God
okay I'll gene you didn't get there good
job there buddy boo all right okay all
right then Oh mosey on my way
Oh fishing pole hello it's a fishing rod
affixed to the ground reel it in GERB
all that's attached to the end is a
photo of a weird-looking monster call me
here's my number you decide not to call
maybe I could just pull constrain things
is it gonna be the same thing yeah weird
looking monster I'm not gonna call that
man maybe someone else down later in the
game is gonna find that out or maybe if
I leave it up someone will find it okay
what's over oh no my heart oh hi ice cap
I don't know what you're all about but
I'm going to compliment you you have a
great hat although who doesn't know I
don't know oh hey whoa wait whoa wait
whoa whoa Wow Wow what are you doing
wait what were you thinking about
thinking about a certain article of
clothing your hat I'm gonna ignore you
tear your eyes away from ice caps at it
looks annoyed hello my house over here
ice cap is secretly checking if you're
looking at Zach no not really continue
not looking at eyes good it's not that
good to be honest seems defeated crying
oh oh really you don't care you don't
care even though you're throwing icicles
out of your head at me desperate for
attention
goodbye 13 gold not bad not bad little
hello so as I was saying about undying
okay sons oh my gosh is that uh human oh
my god ah actually I think that's a rock
oh hi well say I'm from the rock oh my
god is is that a human yeah
oh my god sons I finally did it
unjoin will I'm gonna hold me so popular
popular popular human you shall not pass
this area I agree papyrus will something
I didn't read the rest I will capture
you you will be delivered to the capital
then then I'm not sure what's next
in any case continue only if you dare
well that way well don't sweat a kid
I'll keep an eye socket out for you
thanks thanks buddy
thank you thank you for all that who is
it Toria ring ring uh oh my god help I'd
like to order oh I get it
um pizza with uh the toppings are good i
am i blue copy no I'll just pay some D
your phone is too old to receive text Oh
reads out loud character by character an
ASCII art of an anime cat girl
click okay good prank good prank there's
some narration on this cardboard box you
observe the world crafted sentry station
who could have built this you ponder I
bet it was that very famous Royal
Guardsman notes not yet a very famous
war royal garden oh why did you have to
clarify on your own box you wrote it oh
really
oh yeah well what a stupid hat
oh you're so stupid for wearing it I'm a
very sassy little child goodbye to you
and your stupid hat hello absolutely no
moving well alright then I guess I can
end the episode here then thank you
everybody so much for watching I really
hope you're enjoying undertale so far
this is a charming and delightful game I
love this to death it's awesome so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always house see you in the next
video bye you will succeed
yours knows nobody hears gay little
fighting the Phantom's other than the
offices but guys then happen